all right now before we get started i
don't think the sponsor of this video
this video is brought to you by
skillshare skillshare no stranger to
this channel the online learning
community where millions come together
to expand their creative horizons they
offer a lot of classes to classes on
film and video photography animation
music and that's just the tip of the
iceberg in a world of the pen being
truly mightier than the sword
wanna give some love to their creative
writing classes and their class creative
personal writing write the real you
taught by ashley c ford
it's quite a thing to get your thoughts
and emotions out there in creative
writing furthermore it's also quite a
thing to see those thoughts and emotions
in creative writing
affect other people and the first 1 000
of my subscribers to click the link in
the description will get 30
off a premium annual membership and even
if you've already had a free trial
membership of skillshare you can still
take
advantage of this and for all an annual
membership comes out to less than ten
dollars a month so click the link below
and get started on discovering your path
to discovery redundant speak
yes but that's how i do it and thank you
once again to skillshare for sponsoring
this video
i do appreciate it all right now
[Music]
a quiet place part two so a quiet place
part two is written and directed by john
krasinski it picks up pretty much
right where a quiet place one left off
the abbott family is on the move this
movie stars millicent simmons her her
mother her brother and
new baby they're all on the move and she
embarks on a quest into the treacherous
terrain
of the unknown the treacherous terrain
of hope you don't step on a stick
because if you do you'll die so what i
liked about a quiet place part two
really
it's present in a quiet place part one
this movie like the first one has that
great sense of tone and tension that
tension with no release you know the
kind of tension where you're tightening
a guitar string
and it just doesn't snap you're waiting
for it to snap but it doesn't give you
that release that kind of tension where
you hold your breath and you can't just
release you know you can't just go
oh glad that's over no it's like
that's all present in the first movie
also present in this movie even write
down when people are
walking or they're stepping over or onto
something and you see
everything that can go wrong every
pencil that can roll
every cup that can be knocked over
you're just like this is a disaster i'm
looking at
mouse trap only instead of a board game
it's death that is to say once again
you're going to be watching a movie
in the quietest movie theater ever i
mean movie theaters are at
25 capacity at least in my state they
could be at 150
capacity you can still hear a pin drop
anyone crunching popcorn's like
also i enjoyed the fact that we get a
glimpse of how all of this started it
was a big part of the trailer
is it it was like oh hey the movie's
going to show you how it starts i enjoy
the fact that the movie stays on that
scene a little longer than
i thought it would it's not like it
takes up a large portion of the movie or
anything it's just a glimpse it all
happens before the beginning titles even
come on
but a longer glimpse than i thought it
makes the movie serve as a sequel
and kind of a prequel at least like
prequel glimpse
as much of a prequel as i need for this
world in fact if
every quiet place movie goes back and
shows a little more of what happened
after that a little more of what
happened leading up
i'd be fine with it these little 10
minute glimpses at the beginning of each
movie
perfect also love the fact how this
movie again like the first movie
i told you a lot of what i liked in this
movie is in the first movie but i like
the fact that these quiet place movies
use
sound to craft the world i mean sound is
such a huge part of this like
sound is the make or break live or die
mechanic of the world so it only makes
sense this movie
uses sound to illustrate the moment
illustrate a perspective like it does
with a girl you know she's deaf so when
it's on her in a couple scenes
all the sound goes out which is really
calming gives you that tunnel vision
you're like oh it's
it's just her it simplifies everything
and then you're
met with the feeling of dread of like oh
that tunnel vision means i can't
i'm missing a huge mechanic that can
help me live in this world and
something might be coming up on me so
you go from this feeling of calm to
feeling of anxiety and fear all over
again and in a quiet place too it gets
to the point where
you start seeing where you think it's
going to go and it kind of
you're like oh i've seen this before
killian murphy in the trailer even says
he's like the people who are out there
they're not people we're saving you're
like oh so we're in the walking dead
even at a point i was like this is the
last of us
funny enough it's probably better than
any last of us movie will end up getting
any enjoyable video game movie is an
exception to the rule the rule being
they probably will suck kind of funny a
movie can accidentally do it
but then the movie just kind of it keeps
you on your toes it shakes it up a bit
you're like okay it's not
as cliche as i thought it was going to
be i appreciate that too but this movie
did make me
feel a loss i really felt like emily
blunt's character was kind of pushed to
the side trying to keep this vague for
the sake of no spoilers
but what i liked about the first movie
was the sense of
the family being together them surviving
this situation together
that isn't the case with this movie
there is
there are a couple different things
going on a couple different campaigns
and only one of them really
seems to be moving the plot forward the
other one's waiting around
for monsters to come which having two
different parties does allow them having
two different
groups being terrorized by two different
groups of monsters i mean the kids gotta
grow up sometime i appreciate the fact
that millicent simmons
gets to be in the forefront and gets
that spotlight because she's
great i mean everybody in the movie is
actually great you know she's great
killian murphy's great emily blunt the
son the baby's great in the movie
diamond hunts who's in the movie briefly
but guess what he is that's right he's
great but i i can't help but feel like
they broke up the band
and i felt it and i guess that's a very
subjective thing with me and what i
liked about the first movie
but it is what it is a little secret
reviews they're just subjective thoughts
in the end a quiet place too i thought
it was a really good sequel it had a lot
of what worked in the first movie
present in the second movie if you
enjoyed the first movie you're gonna
enjoy the second movie it's great acting
among a thriller with great tone and
great tension a thriller that's made by
someone who
takes it seriously and it shows there's
care crafted in these quiet place movies
i appreciate that
solid thrills a solid sequel and a great
time no alcohol required all right so a
quiet place part two it doesn't hit
theaters for another
week and a half or so so i'll ask you
are you looking forward to it and what's
one of your favorite thrillers of all
time whatever it is whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]
you